herzlich kommen wieder leute ich hab
heute mag sein bruder an meiner seite
denn wissen heute dass er etwas
besonderen situation max hat mir ein
video für eine lex empfohlen das ich
bisher noch gar nicht gesehen habe und
ich bin sein bevor max theurer chance
hat und zwar wisst ihr ja vielleicht
dass in manchen deutschen großstädten
mittlerweile diese e scooter dieses
futter zur verfügung stehen und
scheinbar gibt es leute die damit nicht
so ganz zufrieden sind es gibt nämlich
ein video von spiegel tv das heißt e
scooter was fußgänger kampf um die
straße und ich will nicht zu viel
vorwegnehmen aber da ist ein ja ein
älterer herr drin wer nicht ganz
zufrieden damit ist dass diese ist er
jetzt auf den deutschen straßen
rumfahren und das ist sehr amüsant
deshalb mal was an dass man uns
anschauen er also leute blind reaction
jetzt quasi von uns beiden ich will auch
versuche außerhalb max olex zu machen
weil wir glaube ich schon so ganz ganz
gutes tun so zusammen sind wir zeigen
leute wir starten reines gewissen ich
bin gespannt in deutschen städten
herrschte scooter alarm kreuz und quer
gern auch in doppelbesetzung erobern sie
die straße ok ich muss man aber sagen
das ist also wohl eher beide in köln
wachsen ich und ja also es ist wirklich
so ist und er hat auch schon einige
dinge gesehen sollte die zu dritt auf
seinem e scooter fahren also war als
person die wir jetzt nicht mehr kann
leute die damit burnouts machen heute
die videos machen also es geht schon
relativ groß auf bestimmte für die einen
sind sie das neue ökologische van gerät
für die anderen eine feindliche invasion
bergwachtmann wer könnte sein
kurzum wer könnte derjenige sein der das
du ein bisschen über die dinge auf ich
weiß jetzt erhielt mit dem weißen
t-shirt er guckt ein bisschen so mit dem
kamera wer fällt mir jetzt noch mehr auf
von diesem bild die frau die vielleicht
nicht ein kind tatsächlich der mann in
dem beauty shot wider erwarten dein
ernst
dieses video trägt so viele leute da
geht etwas mal 3200 likes zu 5000 discs
mehr des lecks als likes unter deutlich
mehr
roland stimpel gehört zum fachverband
fußverkehr die rasenden 2 das geht schon
richtig los was ist seine mission er
will die den fußgängerweg sicherer
machen wie macht man das am besten wie
man die leute einfach noch mal runter
schlägt von diesem scheiß es gut ja das
ist dass sich die beste möglichkeit also
ganz kurz sollte dieser sommer
eigentlich so fahren die fahrräder also
auf dem fahrradweg und wenn halt kein
fahrradweg da ist auf der straße so
natürlich falle damit über den gehweg
und charité es darüber auch was ist die
lösung dafür machen stars verkehr
sicherer indem wir leute die sich mit 20
km haben uns vorbei bewegen am arm
packen und die einfach mal voll auf die
fresse kriegen lassen
man kann wunderbar erkennen wie die
dinge wirklich als hindernisse im weg
rum stehen
deutschland deutschland deutschland muss
man nicht mehr dazu sagen sollte das ist
das land in dem wir leben einfach also
ich meine jedem das seine
ich persönlich hast du schon vom
fachverband fußverkehr bisher was gehört
ich habe man die kommentare geschaut und
es hat jemand geschrieben absolut
zurecht fachverband fußverkehr warum
brauchen wir das links rechts
aber ich finde dieses oder ein gutes
ding für das bildarchiv läuft über die
straße nicht so ein tempo auf der straße
ein gutes ding fürs büro aber genau das
sind so leute die zu uns verklagen würde
dass wir auf diesem volk regieren als
saveiro land stimmte wenn du siehst das
ist kombiniert ist das spaß stehen und
liegen zu fuß ist und wie man ziemlich
viel anlauf nehmen
einen guten sprung gekommen dass man
zusammen man kann dann wunderbar
erkennen wie man ziemlich viel anlauf
nehmen müsste vom brandenburger tor bis
hier und hier noch mit einem guten
sprung darüber zukommen
wirklich jetzt keine privaten person
jetzt darf man das ist schon der typ
sein wasser die hat dieses gewisse
lieblich ich wusste vom brandenburger
tor bis hier und hier noch mit einem
guten sprung rüberzukommen
er weiß dass gerade er hat gerade
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
erfahren dass spaß gemacht so zögert
alter junge ohne willst also ok also ich
finde es nicht schlecht wenn leute sich
so für ihre eigenen interessen einsetzen
und so für das einstehen was ihm
persönlich wichtig ist aber also man
muss auch mal die verhältnismäßigkeit
sehen also es geht einfach darum dass er
nicht will dass leute auf dem gehweg
vaart okay gut da haben jetzt berichtete
von tausenden fußgängern die deswegen
umgekommen sind in deutschland nein das
ist so hart ja er überschlägt sich so
richtig etwas macht hat spaß gemacht hat
es spaß gemacht hast du hier einfach die
ideen von menschen hingerichtet
aber sie haben es einfach noch nicht
groß dass nicht auf dem gehweg soll man
nicht
aber es ist wirklich so dass du bist du
dumm alter hast es nicht gewusst haben
es einfach noch nicht fest aber sagen du
interessierst dich nicht für fußverkehr
was ist dein ernst wir haben nicht auch
hält was ist los hier kannst du einfach
in den verband fussverkehr beende er
heute da leben heute noch heute kannst
du was aus dir machen kommen in den
verband fussverkehr die geht nochmal der
song von eno oder so kommt zu kommen
frontal an
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die fachverband fußverkehr er hat zuerst
gelegt also ich sage das nicht glauben
dann ist er aber unverdrossen weiter auf
dem gehweg gefahren
der roller scheint einem auch das gefühl
zu geben wenn ich einen habe dann darf
ich alles okay also also ohne wird sich
wäre auch so was man weiter gefahren
also ich ja auch nachdem der züge text
hätte sagt dass die leute vernünftig
verteilen flyer meinetwegen siegt am
ende kein das wird sich schon selbst
regulieren sodann muss hat die polizei
ist nach halten also das ist ja durch
die sache also wir haben viele
vorschriften rechtliche vorschriften
deutschland die wirklich sinn machen und
die wichtig sind und wo es auch keine
diskussion darüber gibt ob sie
eingehalten werden zum beispiel nicht
keine ahnung beispielsweise betrunken
autofahren oder man darf an der
menschlichkeit nicht verletzen aber
nicht in ihre würde verletze das ist
wirklich wichtig so und dann gibt auch
keine diskussion das wird eingehalten
aber dann gibt es auch solche
vorschriften wurden vielleicht
vielleicht mal darüber hinwegsehen kann
wenn sie nicht eingehalten werden
ich sage es nur was mir persönlich
wichtig sollte ich will die wahrheit
auch so meinen videos darsteller ich
will nicht irgendwie scheiße erzählen so
natürlich ist gefährlich man muss immer
aufpassen
aber man muss leute auch nicht von
scooter boxen weil sie auf dem
fußgängerweg waren auch die
fahrradstaffel der polizei führt
neuerdings schwerpunktkontrollen durch
warum eigentlich
der andere konnte ja ich glaub es eine
andere statistik berlin eben dass
hamburg jetzt aber dann dürfen die
arbeitsteilung an der einfach roland
stimpel okay also jetzt schon sagen so
was macht die polizei im ortsbereich von
polat in der ist für kontrollen von ist
eine gemeinsame aktion von roland stimmt
und der deutschen polizei aber roland
stimme für die aktion der polizei darf
halt nicht bestimmen wichtige nachhilfe
für alle die keine ahnung von
verkehrsregeln haben
was ist auch dieser ton wir reden die
reden konsequent so als wäre das der
untergang der welt und der untergang der
in der infrastruktur in deutschland
13.000 dinger sind unterwegs wie viele
autos haben wir in deutschland 20
millionen mehr ja ja ich hab 40
millionen pkw oder so ist wissen wir
die welt geht unter wir sagen nein wir
sind in deutschland und es ist etwas
neues in deutschland erschien und das
spiegel tv
nein nein alles so wie viel das bleibt
alles so wie es hier ist nachhilfe für
alle die keine ahnung von verkehrsregeln
haben ja das ist so deutschland
resultieren wir so ein kleiner kauf
trägt alter ja ich weiß dass es nicht
richtig dass wir damit auf ewig favreau
gibt es gibt es möglicherweise
wichtigere themen in deutschland kann
man nicht einfach mal einen hinweis
geben soweit ich weiß ich weiß wie es
rein rechtlich aber ich glaube die
polizei muss in dem fall mit 15 euro
kassieren sollte kann ich aber sagen sie
übrigens ja sie dürfen damit nicht in
der innenstadt fahren wenn ich sie
nochmals ihr dann müssen sie zahlen so
damit jetzt auch mal greifbar um was es
eigentlich geht worum geht es bei einer
grippe meine strafe
die 15 euro gleichzusetzen ist und er
tut so als würde es um mord und
totschlag
bisher galt hamburg so im osten von
hamburg so raub überfall mit geiselnahme
20 menschen sind in lebensgefahr
sek alles ist der kommende freitag im
hamburger westen ist jemand gerade mit
einem e scooter in die fußgängerzone
gefahren also abbruch abrufen müssen
[Musik]
wenn sie damit einverstanden sind weil
das geld bezahlen hey was soll die
scheiße ich hab' ich bin
schwerverbrecher extrahierte verhaftet
nachdem er diesen beitrag gesehen hat
geistig so fit hält zweite session
gürtel außerdem beweist unter 20.000
euro für wohltätige zwecke in ein 20.000
euro an fachverband fußverkehr neben die
besten tipps draußen und läuft in berlin
herrscht auf den gehwegen längst chaos
roland stimpel vom fachverband
fußverkehr sieht vor lauter scooter den
großstadtdschungel schon nicht mehr als
solide aber alter leben und leben lassen
okay vier roller soll auf einem fleck
stehen bestehen neuen da die stehen
nicht mal so ist in einer reihe die sind
perfekt gründlich ordentlich auf gehört
wisst ihr ich bin ein fan davon dass man
probleme so ihrer wichtigkeit nach
angeht und ich darf momentan gibt es in
deutschland wichtigere probleme als
leute die mit e scooter auf dem gehweg
fahren zum beispiel denkt mal drüber
nach wir sehen uns dann am nächsten
video stream geht so einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das lieber roland
vergleichen dankeschön